i was writing some javascript code today
and planned on using one of my all-time
favorite packages faker.js i ran npm
install and it installed version 6.6.6
but when i went to use it i got an
unexpected error message i figured it
was my fault and just the result of a
breaking api change so i went directly
to the github repo but noticed that
there was something weird going on here
all the source code was removed and
there was just one commit with a comment
of end game and in the readme all it
says is what really happened to aaron
swartz um that's actually a really good
question if you don't know who he is
he's an absolute legend who helped
create rss or really simple syndication
the markdown format the creative commons
organization and a website called reddit
his contributions have a major impact on
virtually every web developer out there
but there was one thing about aaron that
some people didn't like you see he
thought information should be free for
everybody and he believed in that so
much that he went into a storage closet
on the mit campus and downloaded a bunch
of academic journals behind a paywall on
jstor or journal storage they caught him
doing this on camera and a few months
later he was arrested journal storage
the victim in this case was very
reasonable and instead of going to court
they just had him return all the
downloaded documents which he did the
u.s attorney's office though wasn't
nearly as understanding he was charged
with a whole bunch of different federal
crimes like wire fraud and computer
fraud where he faced up to 50 years in
prison a while later he was offered a
deal by the feds where he would only
serve six months in prison if he pled
guilty to 13 different crimes aaron
being the badass dude that he was
rejected this ridiculous deal and
instead opted for a trial where the feds
would actually have to justify their
overzealous pursuit of him that's the
right thing to do if you believe in your
cause but it's also extremely risky the
feds have a reputation of railroading
people to make an example out of them
like ross ulbrick of the silk road who
will likely spend the rest of his life
in prison unfortunately in aaron's case
it never went to trial because he would
pass away by suicide on january 11 2013
it's extremely sad to lose such a
talented programmer especially one who
wasn't motivated by money but rather a
higher purpose of making information
free and accessible to everybody he
would likely be appalled by the
censorship that we see in social media
today which includes the very website he
created now some people out there have
speculated that there's more to the
story than meets the eye go back to bed
america your government has figured out
how it all transpired here here's
american gladiators watch this shut up
but now let's get back to our original
question what happened to faker.js if
you're not familiar with it it's a very
popular library with over 1 million
weekly downloads that is used to create
random fake data like names phone
numbers addresses and so on i use it all
the time when building demos for this
channel it's maintained by a github user
who i'm not going to mention in this
video this person highlighted a very
important issue that many open source
developers face in his words
respectfully i am no longer going to
support fortune 500s there isn't much
else to say take this opportunity to
send me a six-figure yearly contract or
if work the project and have somebody
else work on it the response from the
open source community was extremely
positive the sad reality is that there
are many open source contributors out
there who are way undercompensated for
the impact of their contributions mega
corporations startups and consulting
firms all make tons of money on the
shoulders of open source software in
most cases they give nothing back in
return and in some cases people actively
exploit and steal code without following
the proper open source licensing rules
the reality is that to make open source
viable you need to have a good business
plan or you need to be paid a
comfortable salary to make it worthwhile
and sometimes even that's not enough
billion dollar companies like mongodb
and elasticsearch are now releasing
their software under a completely
different open source license that makes
it way more restrictive for big
companies like amazon web services to
take their software and offer it as a
commercial service maybe independent
open source developers should do the
same maybe bitcoin fixes this i'm not
sure let me know what you think in the
comments but if you find yourself
contributing to a library year after
year that has as many downloads as
vue.js while making almost zero dollars
from it you might end up making your own
endgame commit too